[Music]
hey guys welcome back to another episode
of awesome bill a little bit of a cold
so I'm sorry if I sound a little off I
want to start off by saying thank you to
anybody who came out to my channel at
home town cup weeks ago that was
turned out really great I thought was a
good turnout it was a lot of fun it was
a great opportunity to meet a lot of you
and to see some of the things that
you've made and to show off some of the
stuff that I've made in the show in
person and stuff like that it was pretty
cool and yeah it was a lot of fun I
would do it again and for anybody you
guys that that did make it out awesome
it was great to see you and hopefully
I'll be doing more in the future and
I'll keep you guys posted on it so but
today we're going to be doing a scratch
bill we're going to be making some
background spaceships for a project I'm
working on
I've already got I got some of my hero
props and stuff like that models built
and I just need some other ships that
kind of occupy some space in the
background and stuff like that so I'm
going to be just using some regular
around the house kind of items and I
will be using some model parts and stuff
like that I don't have any specific
design that I'm working off of I just
need to build some generic ships to
occupy my background and stuff like that
so they don't have to have a ton of
detail you can definitely apply a lot of
these same techniques to building your
girl props you can make even you know
just using some regular items up around
the house and some old bottles and you
know different containers and stuff like
that you know glued together with some
other stuff or I don't broken toy or you
know some model parts you know chop up
some old models and you know cobble them
together and make a cool ship or
something so this the amount of detail
totally depends on you and how much time
you want to put into it if you're going
to build a hero prop and the more detail
the better if you're building some
background stuff you know I need to
build a bunch of ships in a short amount
of time and with no money so I'm just
going to use whatever items I kind of
have lying around and sometimes it's fun
not to have a design in your head
because then you can kind of be creative
and when you start adding the different
shapes and different containers and
stuff like that and and all these
different elements together in different
ways you kind of come up with a cool
design and just you know right off the
bat I have a whole bin full of different
containers and bottles and stuff like
that that I save so I can use it to do
stuff like this and the dress-up sets
and the dress-up and make different you
know items and stuff like that and come
up and use them in different places so I
went to my band I got like this silk
container which I think is going to be
kind of a cool body to it I've got a few
of these spray can caps and some old
pill bottles some Easter egg pieces I've
got lying around a soap container some
various PVC pieces and stuff and Josh's
Ice Cube or I'm sorry popsicle like tray
thing against dollar store and I had
different caps and stuff and some old
model kit pieces and some styrene I
probably just going to use some styrene
sheets staring you know like these is
for making models for like train models
you can actually build and whatever you
want out of it but you can build
structures out of and stuff like that
buildings anything now you can get them
to look like joists and stuff like that
you can get them already kind of
prefabbed and different elements but you
can just cut them up and these different
you know layers and layers of this
different stuff will give the ship a
texture and everything and then add some
model parts to it and stuff like that
and it'll hopefully kind of give it all
a bit of a texture that makes it look
like you know a cool spaceship so so I'm
just going to kind of play around with
the different elements and see what kind
of happens but yeah let's do it
[Music]
all right so I had a couple of like
applesauce containers and I glued a
couple thing together and I thought this
was kind of a cool possibly cockpit or
something something like like this or
whatever so I add extend this and be a
little bit with PVC and it looks kind of
like the blockade runner from Star Wars
I want to be able to change it up a
little bit no although yeah I think
let's make another cool rusty I'll get a
couple of these but yeah like use
different elements glue together a bunch
of different things glue to it and stuff
like that the different pieces of
styrene to give it some shape and some
body
[Music]
oh yeah
the nice thing about cutting the styrene
is even the sticker pieces thinner
pieces can be cut with an exacto knife
because some of the thicker pieces for
at once and whole today it breaks off
pretty easy it's a very soft plastic
easy to cut it's just a nice if you need
if you have a go you know scroll saw or
retool you could use that but really you
can get all the cuts you really need
versus an exacto knife and straight edge
[Music]
all right well as you can see like
groove the different components together
I just started clogging on a bunch of
different pieces of styrene you had this
little things here like I've got and
gemstones there's a little like pearl
I'm a company I think it's called
gemstone school together sticky backs on
them and stuff like that I wouldn't use
a pieces it's down there not a very
strongly so I used to my Lewis different
we were something like that to glue it
on there buster yeah again just give a
religious fixture as you can see there's
some surface detail it's a different
elements or stuff like that glue down
there but it's not a ton and if you're
doing this at home and you could
definitely just keep adding layers and
layers of texture to really make it time
[Music]
harder
you
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
Oh
stuff quag down right so right now it
looks like a piece of junk and until you
put a paint job on it it's going to look
that way all these different elements
different colors and stuff like that you
know and on the bottle it just looks
like a bunch of you know junk glued to a
bottle but all these developments kind
of give it some texture and when you do
you paint it up and stuff like that
depending you could really weather it
and stuff and it will give it a cool
look I didn't actually use a ton of
model pieces on this I actually just
used a few model pieces here and there
most of it is just diamond pieces or zip
ties I cut up zip ties favor really kind
of a cool texture and so a lot of the
different elements around the back of it
and stuff like that are just zip ties
you know the different paneling and
stuff like that from a distance it looks
pretty cool or it will look nothing
pretty good but up close it's definitely
going to notice all the mistakes and
stuff like that so yes you know
definitely not a hero prop the the
cockpit or front end I guess or whatever
has kind of gotta go like this and yeah
I kind of deliberately I kind of looked
at it as kind of like a space
recreational vehicle you know it's kind
of like you know Winnebago or something
in space you know or like the family
truckster or something so I I kinda
literally put like a grill on the front
of it there to kind of give it the look
of like a family sedan I guess
and then the different you know the two
rocket boosters are going to grow on the
side somehow it's going to have a very
generic kind of retro 80s look which is
what I'm going for
I wanted to have a look like it's sort
of cobbled together using other parts of
ships and stuff like that so yeah once I
start gluing all the elements of stuff
like that together I think it and throw
the paint job on I think is a low look
fairly decent so yeah I think that's it
for today tomorrow we'll glue all the
components together and throw a paint
job on it and see how it looks so we're
back everything is pretty much all the
glue is dried and stuff like that so now
we're just going to glue everything
together and I'm probably going to glue
it mostly with hot glue just to hold it
together so I know it's pretty sturdy
all the pieces are extremely lightweight
because I just made out of lightweight
plastics and bottles and stuff like that
so it should be pretty easy to do all
the components together a little
[Music]
their whole
here's my space family truckster yeah
like I said right now looks like crap
but I think once we start to paint it
it'll start to look like something as
we're going to hit it with a base coat
of krylon flat gray and yeah all over
and the cockpit and the body and stuff
and then we'll go back and do like some
washes and stuff like that kind of make
some of the other little elements pop
and and I have some color and stuff to
it - I'm not sure yet what maybe some
oranges and some blues and stuff I don't
know but
[Music]
Oh
all right so giving it a light dusting
of flattened white kind of made allow
the element to pop out a little bit I
thought it was pretty good and then I
kind of like we dusted the the back of
the thrusters with a flat black and now
I masked off just a few areas then it's
going to do a quick couple of quick
passes with the satin blue I want to be
really intense though I wanted to be
kind of just a few light passes to look
at what make it look kind of like the
paint is wearing off I'm just going to
do it on one side I think so sort of I
know I just like when things are a
little off set or the law balance makes
it look a little more interesting and
then I'll probably go back we'll do a
wash over all the parts and I'll do
probably some random color some like
dark Browns and reds and stuff like that
or oranges for some of the panels and
stuff like that so they kind of pop out
a little bit
all right so now we're just going to do
a wash over all the different components
and stuff like that and make all the
little pieces that we glued on kind of
pop out a little bit more I'm just going
to use some cheap acrylic paint and
water it down so it's really really
runny like ink and I'm going to go over
it
the brush and then dry it off with a
paper towel and then let all those
almonds kind of seep into little cracks
and stuff like that make those almond
cap pop out then I'll use a little bit
to kind of touch up some of the panels
and stuff with some different colors
instead make it stand out a little bit
more but all right
[Music]
[Applause]
killing squabbles too dark just put it
down again it's the water and dry it off
usually get most of it off that early
flight
[Music]
here
all right so when I was putting the
cockpit together I feel a little piece
of painters tape right where I want to
be a window to be so I'm just going to
tear that off and hopefully it gives a
little bit of the frosted plastic and
there the family comes to window
[Music]
when I guess picture I could even put
like a light inside here kind of looming
like that and
[Music]
all right this is what we're left with
all in all I think it turned out pretty
good you know looks pretty good by the
black backdrop you know do we film it
but with the band of blue screen and her
green screen or something like that
then you know you can color correct it
and stuff like that however you want but
ultimately I think it turned out for
easy sync with just items that you can
find around your house some things that
you would normally throw away old
bottles and caps and containers and
things like that as you have lying
around like Pacific Slough the texture I
use zip ties you know I used styrene and
other elements and stuff like that from
model kits but you don't necessarily
have to you can use just bits and pieces
of plastic from other containers that
you cut up and glue on this and or even
you know cardboard or poster boards a
lot of panels and stuff like that - you
were just tape in fact most of the
panels on the face of the cockpit or the
front area are just aluminum tape that I
cut into patterns and stuck on there and
that kind of gives it a raised area an
element of texture and it's incredibly
cheap it's just tape we just cut the
pattern how you want and stick it on
there so it's a quick easy way to kind
of do it and there's a lot of different
elements on here like you know using the
different model parts and stuff like
that does give it a little bit extra
texture look things like the rocket
boosters and stuff like that but like I
said you don't need to especially if
you're not building your hero props you
know if you are if you have a limited
amount of that kind of stuff the model
parts and the styrene then just use that
to build your hero prop you know build
that you know those one that you're
going to be under a lot of scrutiny but
you absolutely could build the hero crap
just using old containers and stuff like
that
repurposed and
rearranged and cut up in different
shapes and stuff so yeah I'll just
inspires you guys to you know stick to
your recyclables and make something out
of the junk plastic that you would
normally just throw away it's a little
bit of paint and yeah becomes in a
pretty cool spaceship front so don't
forget you look me up on Facebook at
James Jim j-rod and as I said I'm not
going to be putting on episodes every
week it's going to be every other week
or every two weeks or something for the
time being until I get caught up on some
of these other projects that are really
big projects and working on and a couple
of big events and stuff coming up too
so because of that I'm going to try and
put these out as frequently as possible
but they won't be every week at least
for a little while so once again thanks
so much for watching you guys take it
easy I'll see you next
[Music]
you